little pencil-neck Adam Schiff so um
today well we don't really know there
could still have been some russia colors
sick sick these are sick people
President Trump taking on house Intel
chair Adam Schiff over his pathetic
alarmism claiming collusion with no
evidence Schiff class today with members
of his own committee at a hearing and my
next guest was among those demanding
that Schiff resign I will not yield mr.
Masterman you because you must make
buildings all of us that I will offer
guys will not sponsor we're gonna say
you attacked me in your opening
statement and I Versailles I have not
had an opportunity respond at all
especially to your statements of what we
think you cannot speak suppose you is
having abused your position to knowingly
promote false information I'm asking for
your resignation day because I believe
you are advancing Putin's work I do not
think that conduct criminal or not is
okay you're not accusing someone of
getting a parking ticket or stealing a
piece of bubblegum you are accusing the
president of treason almost felt like
the House of Commons I got so Rock guys
loved it like the brexit stuff
alright joining me now house Intel
committee member Chris Stewart and the
hills John Solomon who's been reporting
on all of this congressman let's start
with you Schiff is gonna step down right
yeah that's this pie in the sky thinking
so what is the recourse here how can the
committee which is critical to oversight
how could this committee be led by
someone who has lied over and over again
and using the weapon of treason and
trumping a Russian agent well that's
right well our you're right he's not
gonna step down we never realistically
anticipated that he would but we still
had a responsibility to tell him and to
tell the American people the truth and
I'm disappointed that we reached this I
mean that's not the reason that many of
us are on the intelligence community
there's very very important work that we
need to do but we reached a point where
we realize he was so blinded by politics
where he's he's a ruled by emotion and
not fact and we needed to make that
point but Laura if I could tell you what
I think is the the biggest lie
he and others have told and that is as
the clip said they have accused the
president of trees and they have accused
him to aligning himself with a foreign
government not only another foreign
government our adversary for generations
this is a very serious charge and if
they really believed it they would
require they would demand they would
work towards his impeachment I think the
biggest lie here is they don't believe
it's true they know it's not true they
don't want to pretend to be true well
they don't care Congress they don't care
what's good for the country this was
about undoing the results of the
election and whether the America had to
get dragged into this two-and-a-half
year nightmare didn't matter and John
Solomon I gotta tell you Nancy Pelosi's
out there today she was throwing up the
ballast for Forsch if they're just plain
afraid they're afraid of the truth
they're afraid of competence I'm so
proud of the work of Chairman Adam
Schiff what is the president afraid of I
think they're just Garrety cats that's
really high minded rhetoric they're
scaredy cat so I'm rubber you're glue
thanks Nancy listen this is spring
training this is gonna get a lot hotter
before it's all done and here's the big
moment it's gonna happen when that
president that classifies all these
documents and we see in real time what
Adam Schiff was being told behind closed
doors that we can compare with what he
said out front in front of the cameras
Adam shifts gonna be feeling a lot more
uncomfortable than he did today we know
multiple briefings occurred that told
him no collusion and he's out there
driving that narrative when those two
documents can be compared those two
performances I think the American public
are going to be even more concerned than
they are today congressman what kind of
a guy is he
I've only seen him you know usually
thrashing Trump on TV but I mean I've
never met him so what kind of a person
is he well like most of my colleagues
you don't get elected unless you're you
know you're intelligent you're
articulate you're I think in some cases
embracing and he is all of those things
he is a very intelligent he's former
prosecutor he's no fool I'll tell you
that which brings me to that point and
that is he's not being fooled by this he
hasn't been deceived he knows the truth
just like you and I know the truth the
American people know the truth
he just has made a calculated political
decision that he doesn't care what's
true he just hates this president so
viscerally and and is so offended that
the American people would choose this
president over his friend Hillary
Clinton he's essentially said the
American people are stupid we're going
to overturn their decision but we're
gonna do it by destroying this president
through lies and accusations that he
knows isn't true oh look defamation laws
don't apply here but I need to take
issue with how smart Schiff is I mean if
I'm prosecuting I went to law school but
I know a lot of lawyers aren't that
smart I'm a lawyer they're love people
he made like just aren't that smart and
remember what happened not so long ago
when a prankster called him yeah she met
with Trump and she brought him one our
Russian girl celebrity Olga Bulova who
also known as a person with a strange
reputation Oh Olga boobzilla
what's the nature of the compromise well
there were pictures of naked drum it is
a sad saga and the American people are
smart enough to know this and 70% of
Americans said in a poll today in the
hill they trust Muller they're not going
to trust chef on this continuation I
think the bigger question is why keep
extending this shara this Mirage I think
they're trying to keep people away from
what might really have happened and that
is Hillary Clinton's campaign Democratic
National Committee was working with a
foreign power Ukraine to get some of
their dirt on Donald Trump that's what
they don't want people to start digging
into oh you're doing
I've been reading your reporting either
we look forward to the next report and
by the way our colleague Andy Napolitano
said this about well Schiff is kind of
right about mentioning some of this
conspiracy stuff that's watching
congressman Schiff is correct in that
report will be evidence of the existence
of a conspiracy not enough evidence to
prove the existence beyond a reasonable
doubt congressman Schiff wants to dwell
on that if he has other sources he has
to decide when and
under what circumstances to reveal those
sources I don't know why I Andy's
throwing the lifeline to shift there but
real quick congressman yeah I just don't
agree I think I think mr. Barr was
definitive he didn't say and I've made
this point again again he didn't say he
didn't reach a legal threshold that we
found evidence but we couldn't convict
on he said we saw no evidence of
conspiracy he was very clear on this and
I think it's I think it's overly
optimistic for those who oppose his
president to say once again well we
didn't find what we wanted but we'll
keep looking and we'll wait I get the
report who knows what that's gonna sorry
guys we're out of time John thank you so
much congressman thank you